PAIR OF GOALS CONSECUTIVE GAME S
THE ICEBREAKER.
ONE-TIMER PAST THE BLOCKER,
A LATE REACTION FROM
CAMPBELL.
MAYB
THE POWER PLAY.
IT'S 2-0 TAM
OF JACK CAMPBELL THROUGH THEHEA.
IN THE FAST LANE.
WITH THE BACKHAND.
FS' FOURTH LIE
GETS A SHIECHECK.
>> Chris: FIRST SHIFT OF THE
GAME FOR COLIN BLA
IT WENT RIGHT THROUGH HIS
LEGS AND LEAFS ABLE TO CLEAR
IT.
>> Chris: THAT ONE DEFLECTSAL TN
SECONDS OF THE PENALTY KILL.
>> Craiai
GETS IT BACK TO THE BIG
SLOVAK DEFENCEMAN AND HE'LL
START OUTN'T QUITE SURE WHERE
THAT PUCK WAS, IF IT WASL FINALY
GET POINTED IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
MATTHEWS OVER THE LINE WITH
TAVGOOD JOB KEEPING
THE PUCK ALIVE AND GOING
SIDE-TO-SIDE HERE.
THE LINE BY
FOOTE.
NOW THE LEAFS ON THE ATTACK.
TAVARES TO
LEAF BENCH.
MATTHEWS SENDS IT AROUNING BACK.
MORS
THAT JUST MISSED.
>> Craig: A LIT
SHOT OF THE SERIES AFTG TO GET T
BACK IN FRONT.
BSO KILLORN OUT
WITH POINT.
NYLANDER'S IN.
WIDEUP AHEAD, TOO FAR FOR POINT.
NOW SLIDE TO CAMPBELL. FOUR SHOL
TONIGHT.
HAGEL AGAIN AS THIS THIRD
LINE FOR THE LIGHTNING GO TECRE.
THEY STARTED GAME 4 WITH THE
ENERGY. KUCHEROV,
STOPPED BY CAMPBELL.
STEVEN STA
THE MAN WHO HAS EQUALIZED
THE GAME, , E LIGHTNING TAKING
CARE OF THEUES KNOCKED
LOOSE BY KAMPF.
PERRY, FELL AT THE LINE.
THAT'S GOING TO BE ICING AS
PE